[Music]
that's right people don't burn this
country is officially out
[Applause]
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
stay calm
everyone what's the procedure
you can get your copy at daverubin.com
book do you read it yes there are two we
are now number one and that's gotta be a
real shame if you are over at number
four there the anti-racism
i'm the baby but
is it racist that's right don't buy that
that's not good this book is about the
things that you can do to survive and
thrive
[Applause]
davereuben.com events if you want to
join me on tour and if you get a vip
ticket as you know you get the one
second hug
all right people today
is
a big day
it is april 12th in the year 2022
and it is
don't
burn this country day if i'm not
mistaken guys i was told this morning
that joe biden has declared today a
national holiday in celebration of the
publication of my second book don't burn
this country of which i am surrounded by
right now i've got tons of books here
this is very
very exciting this is the one day that
joe biden said in his speech this
morning as he was declaring today don't
burn this country day he said today's
the one day he won't burn this country
that's what joe biden said in the speech
it was unclear if he was ad-libbing that
or if that was off the prompter but i'm
super excited for today we're getting a
ton of love the book is selling like
crazy we're topping most of the
important amazon charts uh if you have
not picked up the book already in either
book form this is an actual physical
book with words made out of paper
or in audiobook form which obviously a
lot of you guys because you listen to
podcasts and your cool tech savvy cats
you can pick up either version at amazon
barnes and noble et cetera et cetera you
know where to do that go to
davereuben.com
book and what we're going to be doing
today
because i want to celebrate those of you
who who have been my biggest supporters
you know the original the first 5 000
books sold we offered to our locals
community to get signed uh numbered book
plates so the numbered book plates
actual one through five thousand
now i've got all sorts of stuff to sign
here so what we're going to be doing
today is if you buy the book now through
noon eastern for the next hour or so
every single person that buys a book
either at davereuben.com books all you
got to do is just forward us
your email you're going to buy the book
and then just forward us the email at
contact reubenreport.com and i'm going
to sign
one of these for you now these that we
have here what this is now you may
remember we sent out 75 of these
influencer boxes right this had the book
in it and i sent these out to all sorts
of people to ben shapiro to jordan
peters and douglas murray my whole crew
we just sent these out as sort of thank
yous for support and friendship and all
that stuff but they all included this
little special note that we had and but
we have about a hundred extra of these
because we only sent out about 75 boxes
but for some reason they sent us about
200 of these so i want to send these to
you they'll never be printed again
they're one of a kind i will sign them
on air for you and i'm going to write
your name on the freaking thing for you
i've got sharpies i've got shellacked
paper i've got books all of that stuff
so all you got to do while you are
watching the show today buy the book
wherever you buy it amazon barnes and
noble your local bookstore just forward
us the receipt
at contact
reubenreport and if you want it
personalized you can put a name in there
and we will do that or if you want to
buy a ticket to the tour which comes
with a book
this is a lot of information for these
good people
you can just forward us the receipt for
the tour tickets to contact
reubenreport.com and i will also send
you one of these and sign it and if you
buy vip tickets i'll sign the book again
when i meet you and as per the video
earlier you will get the one second hug
by the way shout out to conor who put
that video together that was a little
surprise for me this morning on uh book
publishing date uh so today we're gonna
do a little review of some of the ideas
in the book and you know what i've been
talking about a lot lately obviously is
okay
we're surrounded by morons all right the
democrats are psychotic the leftists are
lunatics all of our institutions are
melting but the whole purpose of this
book is there is a way out it really is
i've been hinting at a lot of the ways
out we have to build new things we have
to think about the world a little bit
differently we have to disconnect from
some of the bad people and bad ideas
that's really what the purpose of this
is as the subtitle
says i want you to thrive
not just survive this woke dystopia that
we live in because we're in it right
boys are girls non-racists are racists
two plus two is five we are in dystopia
we're in it right now this is it this is
how it feels i know we all thought
dystopia would have a little more synth
wave music and we'd all be wearing you
know unicolor uh outfits or something
like that from star trek but no this is
what modern dystopia is like this is
what reality dystopia is like but there
are ways out and i want you not only to
survive through it which a lot of us are
just kind of surviving day to day we
wake up more nonsense comes things get
slightly worse we wake up the next day
more nonsense comes things get slightly
worse we wake up the next day rinse and
repeat over and over again but truly
that's that's the purpose of this book
let's fight this thing we can fight we
can thrive i think i'm a living
breathing example of it that you can
figure out ways to thrive in all of this
madness i mean look look what i was able
to build here uh so we're going to talk
a little bit about that we'll do some of
the the current events kind of stuff and
all that good stuff but first real quick
i just want to tell you there is
something major going on with one of the
tour stops so you know i've been teasing
out all of these tour stops all along
and just real quick uh and most of the
vip tickets are sold out already but i
think there are some left and there are
general admission don jr will be with me
in west palm beach benny johnson in
clearwater florida andrew clavin in
raleigh north carolina michael malus in
atlanta phoenix keep it rolling yonmi
park in chicago glenn beck in dallas
meghan mccain in d.c megan kelly in west
niagara new york dennis prager in brea
california larry elder in oxnard
california dennis douglas murray in san
jose california blake masters in phoenix
arizona and i'm hearing that there will
be a charlie kirk appearance at that one
as well and brian callan in denver now
many of you have been asking dave what
happened
to orlando the whole tour was supposed
to kick off this coming monday april
18th in orlando and then suddenly a day
or two ago we disappeared the orlando
show and people were freaking they our
email was blowing up people were
freaking texting me trying to get me
what's going on here okay so here's the
deal if you have tickets to the orlando
show do not do anything
we are moving the date of the orlando
show because we have landed
a huge gas
i cannot say who yet because we're
waiting for like a signature on
something basically
but it is basically
the best guest that i could possibly get
that's i'm willing to say that much i'm
willing to say that much yes it is the
best guess i could possibly get and it
was worthy of us changing the date on
this orlando show so the link for the
orlando show will go back up
trust me this thing is going to sell out
super quick i hopefully can announce it
we could find out actually during this
live stream that i can actually announce
it i think you can probably guess as to
who it might be someone is big he's big
you know what i'm saying
so don't do anything if you've got the
orlando tickets yes the date is changing
uh and if for whatever reason you can't
make the alternate date obviously you'll
get a refund but otherwise your tickets
are good and if we've caused any
inconvenience for any of you if there's
anything we can do
the two-second hug you want me to sign
something extra we'll figure it all out
it's all good people so i'm very excited
and uh again you can get tickets to the
uh tour at daverubin.com events oh are
you trying to hand me something is that
what's going on here here there all
right there we go let's talk though
before we do anything else let's talk
about some wine people they're handing
me wine on the show i thought this was a
celebratory champagne but it is a
beautiful malbec
i think perhaps from argentina do you
know what's in the wine bottle sitting
on your kitchen counter people no
traditional media won't tell you this
try oak flavoring mega purple dye and
tons of sugar and that's not counting
all the chemicals left over from the
vineyards that look more like oil
refineries than the great chateaus of
old but better wines do exist and they
don't cost an arm and a leg either take
it from america's top wine explorer
recently he came across a wine unlike
anything he's ever tasted problem is
this delicious red wine can only be
found in a single isolated corridor
known as the world's most remote wine
valley he nearly died twice trying to
find these vineyards the wine is that
special so i think you should give them
a try today over at bonner private wines
my audience can get these rare wines at
half the retail price no need for a
promo code plus you'll get 50 off
shipping the wine is truly something
special but supplies are limited visit
bonner
privatewines.com dave to claim your wife
that's bonner privatewise.com slash
david now back to me i made a seriously
awesome smoke tri tip on sunday night
and we knocked out a bottle of this and
it is quite
spectacular okay
so i want to talk to you obviously a bit
about the book we're going to do some q
a as well so anyone right now if you if
you buy a ticket to the tour or you buy
the book and you fold us the receipt
contact reubenreport.com you can also
put a question in so we'll take some
questions we've already loaded up a
bunch from the locals community and um
i'm looking forward to the uh to the
program oh and i'm all over the media by
the way in case you're not sick of me
yet could people ever be sick of me
would would that be possible
i'm i'm sort of doing a million shows
over the course of the next couple days
uh i did glenn beck's radio show i was
on patrick bet david's show a couple
days ago i'm on ben shapiro today megan
kelly right after this eric matax's will
kane's podcast i'll be on kennedy on fox
tonight later this week outside michael
shermer ben dominic america's newsroom
chad prather spicer and company john
bachman prager whitlock eric bolling
tpusa live charlie kirk prageru i got a
new preg review video out next week okay
okay okay promo blah blah blah you got
the idea if you get the book just
forward the receipt contact
reubenreport.com i'm going to sign one
of these for you guys i'll even
personalize it for you and you get to
ask me a question right now so
let me talk a little bit about
the book why i wrote the book and all of
this stuff so you know when i wrote
don't burn this book which i wrote
mostly in
2018 and i was on tour with jordan
peterson when i got the offer for the
book uh some of you actually may
remember the story i think i've told it
once or twice we were in uh dublin
and i had a meeting we had got a couple
offers to do a book my agent had sort of
wanted me to do a book for a while but i
felt i was just very busy with the show
and the tour and everything else we got
a couple offers and and then i finally
decided to do it and uh we actually we
got the offer
no we had the initial discussion while
we were in dublin and then we got the
offer when we were in oslo and oslo was
one of the biggest shows that jordan and
i were doing and i got the offer
literally about a minute and a half
before we were about to walk on stage
and i got the offer i walked into
jordan's dressing room david was with me
and tammy was with jordan and i said
jordan i just got the the offer for the
book and i told him a little bit about
it and with my idea and he in just
perfect jordan peterson fashion he was
sitting in a in a swirly chair
smacked his hands he had the biggest
smile that wasn't a good smack
like you know it was just like one of
those like pure yeah like that like just
joyous slaps like huge smiles he spun
around like 360 in his chair got a big
hug he was so excited for me and then i
started writing the book throughout the
rest of the tour so i wrote the book in
2018 into 2019 the book didn't come out
till april 2020 which at that point we
were already in lockdown the whole tour
i had a i had a worldwide tour we were
going to go into europe and a whole
bunch of other places in canada and i
think we're going to go to australia
that whole thing obviously got decimated
but that book came out and and don't
burn this book really was hey these are
my ideas these are the classically
liberal principles that i try to live by
i also talk a little bit about my own
evolution obviously related to
belief and and my political evolution of
course and a whole bunch of other stuff
and then two years go by and this covet
thing happens and we lock people in
their houses and we depress people and
we destroy jobs and we
ruin so many of the brilliant ideas that
have freed people in western societies
for all of these years
and over the course of the last
year and a half or about a year and a
half ago i thought well if i'm going to
be locked at home anyway we should
probably be thinking about writing
something else and i talked to
my publisher and they immediately wanted
to do it because the book the first book
did obviously really well and i thought
well what's the next step in this and
the next step is okay we can talk about
ideas forever and like there's a certain
set of irony with that right i i'm a
talker for a living i try to communicate
these ideas to you translate some of
this nonsense so you guys can take it
and
hopefully live a decent life
um
and i thought but it's not just enough
to talk we have to do some stuff and and
i had done some stuff along the way you
know i wasn't happy with big tech and i
started locals
um i had sort of evolved on a personal
level and that we decided that we were
going to have kids which was a huge jump
i mean make that's almost the biggest
decision that you can make to actually
do something create something new quite
literally in this world um to really be
part of building a completely alternate
media landscape i mean what's happening
right now with i would say the blaze and
the daily wire and prageru and rumble
and locals like we're really building
something that will be able to put the
other thing in the past so there will be
a day and i don't think it's in the too
far off future
where i'll be able to say you know what
we don't have to show clips of joy read
anymore because not only do we know not
that many people are watching but the
cultural relevance of joy reid and the
clowns at msnbc and even the buffoons
in the administration and the liars and
all the people that we make fun of here
we won't have to pay that much attention
to them anymore because if we build the
proper institutions and we build the
proper media companies and all of those
things then
we won't be dependent on them they won't
have that much influence over us so in
many ways i talk a lot about that kind
of stuff um also i wrote the book
um while
well the way the editing process works
you're writing the book then you put it
down for a while then you have to pick
it up again so i at the beginning of the
book i was in la by the end of the
editing process i was already on my way
to florida but but part of what i was
writing about and thinking about was how
you've got that football football thing
that i'm always talking about and that
you should live in places that are more
in line with your lifestyle and and in
these last three months here i think i
began to thrive in a new way because of
moving to the free state of florida uh
so i get into a whole bunch of stuff in
the book about the fertility process and
and adopting clyde at the same time that
we literally
we
uh
don't it's not you're not donating
you're depositing your sperm and then we
were it was during lockdown and we had
to run to the fertility clinic and i'm
running to the fork utility clinic as
they're locking everything down it was
really a weird day it was very windy in
l.a that day and they were saying we
have to lock everything down and you got
to get us your sperm immediately and i'm
running there to give them some sperm
and i had just found out that they were
going to kill all these dogs so i wanted
to get to the dog shelter and also emma
our previous dog who we just loved and
adored for 16 wonderful years she had
just passed away we didn't want to get a
dog yet but i had to save another dog
because they were going to kill the dogs
we got a deposit sperm we got to get a
dog that's the whole thing the
lockdown's happening we run into the uh
we run into the sperm clinic and who's
standing outside the sperm clinic dennis
rodman dennis rodman standing outside
the sperm clinic sperm clinic and right
as i get out of the car and i'm walking
into the sperm clinic and i see dennis
rodman to my left donald trump jr calls
me to ask what i think about all the
lockdown stuff and i'm thinking oh man
i'm on the phone with the son of the
president of the united states i got a
former nba legend standing outside of a
sperm clinic i got to go do my business
up in there we got to go save this dog
it was a hell of a day so anyway i get
into that story and a whole bunch of
other stuff i talk a little bit about my
going off the grid experience that you
guys know i do do every year uh why
leaving patreon starting locals was so
important some of the ways
that you can fight what i call the
bravery deficit you may have seen the
the video that i did a couple years back
uh from for prageru about the bravery
deficit that we're all we all know
something's wrong
and and we're just not saying it we're
not addressing it we're not doing
anything in our own lives
to to
push back against it and and i really
mean this i i don't think i am anyone
special i am one guy and i just started
saying the things that i thought and by
the way it comes with plenty of hate i
get plenty of hate and as you know years
ago when i first started getting hate
from the supposedly tolerant lovely
diverse
lefties and progressives
i developed alopecia much like will
smith's wife what's her name jada
pinkett smith
now i don't run around hitting people uh
but and it's all my hair back which is
very exciting um
but
you get a lot of hate but but the more
that you're quiet the more that you give
room you give oxygen you give energy to
the people that are destroying
everything uh so i i talk about that i
go into a little bit about my my history
doing stand-up um you know and then
that's all couched of course in this
idea that i did actually then make the
move and that's what i'm trying to show
you here that the the action is the key
part so making the move from california
to florida and the rest of it so there's
there's a whole bunch of stuff in the
book i want to answer a bunch of your
questions as i said if you buy the book
during this live stream until noon today
there's only about 100 of these left
i'll show you exactly how many we got i
counted them on the way upstairs today i
got to about 90 and i think i had about
10 left this is what we got so the first
hundred of you that buy the book during
this live stream and most of them will
go to the locals community i think um
we'll i'll personalize it for you i'll
sign it for you all you have to do is
forward your book receipt or your ticket
for the tour receipt to contact
reubenreport.com and i will sign it for
you
that's just a straight up signature
right there there you go but i will even
put your name on it if you want and
there there's only 75 others of these
jordan peterson's got one shapiro's got
one my whole crew glenn beck's got one
and you yourself you good wonderful
person
uh you can have one too uh so you
forward those receipts to contact
reubenreport.com and put a question in
there and i will do
some questions today as well i'll answer
anything and everything
and we got one more ad for you and then
i'm going to get to all of that uh real
quick guys i want to talk about
cryptocurrency because you know it may
represent the future of money i think we
all know that at this point it's one of
the most exciting investment
opportunities to come around for some
time but what about taxes well with an
alto crypto ira you can trade crypto
like bitcoin and avoid or defer these
taxes set up your account in minutes at
no charge today invest with as little as
ten dollars and trade all you want ready
to take your investments to the next
level diversify like the pros and trade
without tax headaches open an alto
crypto ira with just as little as ten
dollars just go to alto ira.com ruben
that's a l t o i r a dot com slash ruben
start investing in crypto today go to
alto ira.com ruben and now back to me
all right so let's get to some questions
and i will sign things and personalize
them for you you guys can throw me some
names as things are
coming through the uh the prompter there
and uh look we've already hit number one
on a bunch of the charts we know this
thing is uh selling really well and i'm
just i'm excited and i'm
flattered and i'm honored and i'm
humbled and all of
that good stuff and we're having sushi
for lunch today they said to me dave
today you can have lunch because you
wrote the book and you worked very hard
you can have lunch today they usually
starve me
but i said let's have sushi so sushi is
in the house today
kat says how do we not lose hope when
inflation is at insane levels stores
have empty shelves gas prices are at an
all-time high and there's no end in
sight people are still whining about
mean trump as our country is crumbling
before our eyes i go days without
looking at any sort of news because it's
all so depressing but when i go back to
see what's happening and think uh and
things are looking worse than before i
took the break thanks for doing what you
do and pointing out how we can fight
back and try to muddle through well
first off look there is a lot of bad
news there is a lot of bad news just i
think in the last hour
they released some new inflation numbers
is it up to eight point five percent is
that what i saw just before yeah about
eight point five percent that in essence
means every time inflation goes up that
means the currency is worth that much
less right so
the more inflation goes up it is a tax
on you it is in essence your dollar is
worth 8.5
less now there's always a little bit of
inflation but you want inflation low so
that your your money goes further and
then what happens when your money
doesn't go as far then the price is of
good it becomes this deal in hell the
prices of goods get raised because the
guy at the store needs to make more
money because his money is devalued less
the the cost of fuel starts going up
because the guys in the trucks their
money to gas up the truck is worthless
like you can see how it just spreads and
proliferates throughout the economy so
look just economically alone there's a
lot of problems right now in the supply
chain stuff and all that but but sort of
everything that
i've been talking about on this show and
that you guys just know in your lives
like there are less things on the
shelves it's taking longer to order
basic products we have this very bizarre
war in russia and ukraine and it's like
we're not in the war but we're at war
there was the disaster in afghanistan
like i don't have to go through all the
stuff you get it so the question really
is
sort of what do we do in that well i've
laid out actually in this in this book
here that happens to be coming out today
i've laid out a lot of the ways you can
disconnect from some of this stuff you
really can and even if that meant in
your life like watching less of these
shows i i hope i provide something here
that's a little bit different than some
of the other shows and you get to laugh
a lot and that's what makes
me enjoy this the most and when i see
the comments and a lot of people
yesterday were saying it was the
funniest show we'd ever done it's like
to me that's like the great part of this
and if i can make you laugh while maybe
learning a little something or getting a
little
like somehow pilfering a little truth
out of the endless cacophony of insanity
that these people are pushing on us all
the time then that's pretty great but i
would say that you just have to think
about your life a little bit differently
one of the things that i go into in the
book is you know if you're if you're 17
right now so you're like a junior in
high school
everyone's telling you you've got to go
to college you don't have to go to
college you don't have to go to a
four-year school where most likely
you're going to be brainwashed to walk
out of it with 120 000 worth of debt
with a with a degree
in 18th century lesbian poetry uh to
think that you're going to become
whatever it is that you want to become
and actually in the book this is one of
the things i'm most proud of in the
entire book so in the book i tell the
story of
phoenix who's sitting right there who's
my associate producer right now and i
wrote the book again about a year and a
half ago and he was interning for us
about a year and a half ago and he was
going to college and his internship was
wrapping up because he had to go back to
school and i said to him we had a sit
down
and he was thanking me for the
opportunity everything and i said to him
you know if you want a job
you should stay and we'll give you a job
you don't have to go back to school and
we pay all your benefits and you get a
great job and i think you have a bright
future in front of you and he was like
no i think i think i do want to go back
and then he went back for what do you go
back for like eight months or you went a
year basically a full year went back and
it was zoom and it was
campus was closed and open whatever it
was the experience wasn't coming
together the way he wanted and then he
called us one day and he said dave does
that offer still stand and and now he
has a full-time job benefits all that
good stuff living on his own for his for
the first time great apartment how's
life these days
amazing amazing you hear that emphasis
on the uh amazing that's what he said
and and i tell you that story because
i wrote the first part of it in the book
i didn't know he was gonna end up
actually taking my advice but here's the
living proof of it right here so that's
a young person saying hey i don't need
to be part of the system that they put
out i don't need to be indoctrinated and
go into debt to be indoctrinated for no
reason there are ways that you can do
things a little bit better and i think
that's part of it so whatever is going
on in your life like be less reliant on
those systems you know one of the big
issues that we have right now is that
millennials
they don't know how to do much change a
tire or grow some food or some basic
stuff and then we all become more
reliant on these systems imagine if the
grid the the real grid i'm not just
talking about the power grid like
electricity went out for two days
although imagine if electricity went out
for two days actually we had a little
power outage here this pretty bad storm
about a week ago on a saturday night and
our power went not our power our
internet went out power was fine but the
internet went out for about three hours
and we realized we had nothing to watch
we were in the middle of watching uh the
gilded age on hbo but then you can't
access anything without internet
and uh you know we we played checkers we
actually played checkers david wanted to
play chess believe it or not now i'm
going to embarrass myself i don't know
how to play chess he wants to teach me i
don't know how to play chess so we
played we played checkers um but we're
all reliant on these things um so
whether that's building you know getting
off the grid with a tesla powerwall
which of course is expensive but there's
other ways to do it or knowing how to
grow some food like there's actually
some things we all became a little more
kind of preppery didn't we over the last
two years having a little more food
maybe in a backup freezer that you have
in the garage maybe buying a gun for the
first time which is what we did um
those type of things like stop being so
reliant if government was as small as it
was intended to be the stupid decisions
of joe biden and the rest of these
criminals almost at this point they
wouldn't matter that much so that's all
i've got to say about that catherine
is asking a question catherine i'm going
to personalize this for you right now i
forgot that's what i'm supposed to be
doing at the same time
katherine
your question is at the tour will you
have hard copies of your book to
purchase for family and friends yeah
first off every single ticket vip
regular general admission etc they all
come with a copy of the book and i
believe we will have extra copies to
sell we will have extra we're going to
bring some if not i'll give them to you
if they're not selling them it seems
that you would sell books at the show so
yeah you will be able to get extra books
there and i will sign all the vip copies
for everyone that does the old meet and
greet and if you would like to join me
on tour in case you have not been paying
attention it is daverubin.com
uh raw says while you were writing were
there ever any nights you dreamed about
the book or parts of it pleasant
unpleasant nightmares you know it's
funny raw r-a-w-e
i'm signing that to you um
i have a i have a very consistent uh
nightmare throughout my life or at least
throughout the adult part of my life for
the last 15 or 20 years uh which is and
then i'll answer the book question
specifically because i think you'll see
the connection um is that i'm going on a
tv show and they either forget to record
it or my microphone won't work so i used
to when i was doing a lot of stand-up i
used to always have a dream that i was
going on the tonight show it was usually
the the or the le it was the letterman
show so whatever that was the late show
and that i would be he'd bring me out
and i'd go up there to start doing my
thing and the microphone would not be
working and nobody could hear me that
would be one or i'd have another one i
had this one a lot where i'd be guest
hosting the daily show and i'd crush it
and then right at the end they would
tell me that they forgot to broadcast it
so like
like that sort of thing you can see a
sort of theme there so i did several
times during writing this book and
during the first book i would have
dreams that i wrote the book but i
forgot to hand in the script or
something like hand in the manuscript or
that they lost it or the publishers just
couldn't publish it like many versions
of that sort of thing there's definitely
something there there's definitely
something there about
like
my relationship with the system or
something like that um but that that
would be the main dream related to that
i you know actually every now and again
one thing that i've found very helpful
is if you ever write a book or
do anything somewhat creative if you're
like really trying to kind of noodle
something noodle through something
creatively uh if you just keep a little
piece of paper or a small notebook next
to your bed preferably with a sharpie
instead of a little pen
that way because you know a lot of times
you wake up in the middle of the night
and you've had this dream
that you can't quite piece together but
you're like man i got something like
something just happened i just had a
thought that i know is real and true and
something just was i just got something
out of my brain through the ether it
just came together um but you forget
them right almost the second that you
remember them you forget them it's sort
of the magic of what dreams are so a lot
of times i would just kind of scribble
down something real quick sometimes i
would i would literally there's an
episode of seinfeld where this happens
to him but i would literally just
scribble down a word and then i'd wake
up and i'd have no idea what i was
talking about like i would just look at
it and be like what what did i mean
by blue chicken like what what actually
did that mean and then i wouldn't be
able to figure it out sometimes
there's the episode of seinfeld where he
was doing that he'd think of a joke in
the middle of night write it down then
he didn't know what he wrote so i think
a sharpie is better because you're more
inclined to be able to read it rather
than if you scribble with a little a
little just regular pen uh amy you're
getting a
signed
book
plate here
did you experience writer's block or did
the insanity of our world today provide
you with an overabundance of content um
it was a little different writing this
one than the other one the first book
was very easy even though it was my
first in a way it was very easy because
it was it was about all of the stuff
that that i had been talking about for
so many years right so in some ways oh
actually like we quoted
i actually quoted from the prageru
videos that i had done and some of the
interviews that i had done this book is
as you'll see it's a little more
research heavy it's a little bit it's a
little bit more historical
so it's a different if it's a different
type of book you'll feel the moments
where i kind of really lock into like
where i'm just sort of on a run of my
own stuff and you'll see the silly star
wars references and that kind of thing
um but i but writer's block yeah there
are kind of days well it's not even
writer's block as much as like there are
just days where you just go to the well
and there's just not much there or
there's a million other things happening
in life
and you know also the other thing with
writing as i said the process is really
slow so you write for however many runs
months you write for it i think it was
about six months or so
and then you hand the book to the editor
the editor then looks at it for a couple
months so i handed the book to the
editor if i'm not mistaken right before
i went off the grid in august so it was
in july my editor looked at it for about
two months then we have about a month or
two of edits so then i was editing the
book as i was moving
so i was also my my mindset had shifted
a lot so we removed some stuff related
to california um but you'll actually see
just if you want to know sort of the the
slow process of of the book world and it
just is what it is i'm actually it's
it's just it's just a process that has
existed on the uh on the inside flap of
the book where they have my bio here my
bio actually says i still live in los
angeles because a lot of this in terms
of the the sort of functional part of
printing a book and everything else had
been done before but in here you'll see
moments where i say i'm on my way to
florida so it's just it's just one of
those things jc you're getting a card jc
says how is writing this book different
from your first one which i love well i
sort of addressed that
i sort of addressed that just now um
but what else can i tell you related to
this one um
well the first one
i didn't know how to do it i actually
didn't know what i was doing i just kind
of had scribbled some things down and i
would get on the phone or usually on
facetime with my editor helen healy who
is just an absolute all-star helen you
better be watching this right now um and
i think we'll be a publishing legend one
day if not if not already she's already
published a couple new york times
bestsellers she's just great not that
the new york times bestseller list means
anything and it's a complete sham and i
want to get on it next week so that we
can uh just even further prove what a
sham it is because they won't put me at
whatever number i'm supposed to be at
which is what they did last time and
glenn beck by the way you want to know
what a bananas
sham the new york times bestseller list
is has any author ever done this in the
history of writing on the day of
printing talk about what a ridiculous
list it is glenn beck like two weeks ago
his book the great reset can i get the
date on that what day did that come out
it came out about a month ago if i'm not
mistaken maybe even six weeks ago um it
that book is crushing it at
extraordinary levels glenn has written
i don't know at least a dozen books
probably and this is by far his
best-selling book and about two weeks
ago it was still selling 60 000 hard
copies i believe it was 57 000 hard
copies because you can't fudge sales
numbers sales numbers are legit you just
cannot fudge them
but the new york times put a whole bunch
of books like eight books that had sold
around 2 000 copies on their top list of
i think they do the top 15 list they had
all these books with 2 000 3 000 4 000
copies and then i think at number 11
they had glenn beck with 57
000 copies so they have a best-seller
list that you think is about sales and
then you find out it's their own special
formula and and man if the new york
times is fudging with numbers with what
we believe to be numbers just sales
numbers something actually tangible what
do you think they're fudging with when
it comes to the news and the other ways
they might want to manipulate you
january is that what i saw yeah so his
book came out in january we are now in
april and at one point they couldn't
even print enough to sell them
so that tells you a little bit about how
he's crushing it which i love being
around people that are crushing it in
more extraordinary ways because then it
makes you it makes you want more it's
like man glenn 10 books in 57 000 copies
three months later we got a lot of work
to do like that that's you know when you
play basketball you want to be around a
better player because they'll make you
better uh that's a beautiful thing um
beth did you always want to be a writer
um
it's funny in a weird way now beth i'm
signing this for you
um
did i always want to be a writer no
actually um when we started getting some
offers as i said i was on tour with
jordan peterson and i was i was so lucky
to be just
in the limelight of that thing you know
jordan at his at his
peak and the best of the best and he's
been pretty great for this past year
that he's been back to
but to be on that worldwide tour that
that everyone said everyone everyone
professional related to that tour the
agents the bookers
the lawyers everybody the audience
members like they had never seen
anything like that before it's one thing
to get rockstar sellouts when you're a
rock group it's one thing to get
rockstar sellouts when
uh you're a comedian but he was getting
every single show selling out often in
minutes people turning their lives
around all this stuff and i was around
that and it started making me think
there is something that i'm part of here
that i do have something unique to say
you know i sort of came on in
maybe in the back door in a way like as
an interviewer right so my garage
that's where most of those shows took
place years ago it was literally the
garage of my home it was the center for
uh what was eventually called the
intellectual dark web and we were sort
of at the beginning of discussing all of
these things that are wrong with society
and in some ways in some ways all of our
discussions as valuable as they were
they didn't work enough because things
have proceeded to get worse but that's
also why i wanted to write this book
because now it's enough it's enough
talking we have to do something to stop
this insanity so i don't think i
considered myself a writer
purely in that sense of you know i want
to go out to uh
to the forest somewhere in the winter
and you know write my book like this is
misery and then at the end smokes my
cigarette and drive a thing and then you
fall off the thing and then the ladies
we're whacking you in the legs anyway
getting the reference here i think some
of you are um i wasn't thinking about it
that way i don't even have a really a
real writing jacket and i also don't
have a great desk for i really have a
wonderful house here in l.a we had a
great house
but i kind of write in crazy ways i'll
just like grab my computer and i'll be
sitting at the kitchen desk or i'll be
sitting on the couch or i'll be sitting
outside or i'll literally be in the pool
and i'll be like i gotta think that
through and i'll grab my phone
so i in that regard i'm not that
organized which is why having a great
editor and a great team of people around
me kind of helped tightens it but
everyone does a little bit different
justin
says and justin you're getting a
personalized book plate right now i
should be signing these a little faster
i suppose
is the content something that can be
embraced by moderate democrats yes let
me answer that real quick but if you're
just joining us just now if you want one
of these signed this is there's only
about 100 of these left and then and
then i have extras because well i'll
sign as many as i have to today we
printed out some extra things that we
will send you as well uh but these are
the ones going to all the the influencer
all-stars that got these fancy boxes
that we sent out with the book in them
right there uh you can just buy the book
right now at davereuben.com book or buy
a tour ticket at daverubin.com events
forward the receipt to contact
reubenreport.com and i'm going to sign
one of these for you and you can ask a
question in that email that i'll try to
get to right here that we're going to go
as long as we're going to go till we'll
try to go oh man we're running out of
time
ah i got i got meg and kelly at noon so
we don't have a lot of time so i got to
go faster here uh what was the question
what was the question the previous
question
uh justin is the content yes great
question yes absolutely can the content
be embraced by moderate dems i hope so i
really hope so look i know i make fun of
the democrats all the time
so many of them have lost their mind
you've got these quasi-sane ones like a
bill maher something like that but i
want to drag these people and maybe it
has to be kicking and screaming i want
to drag them to the promised land i want
to show them that there's a freer better
america something that's more reliant on
you that your self-reliance is the thing
that can save you and i think a lot of
moderate democrats are open to that now
now like you cannot be a moderate
democrat and think that the democrat
party of 2022 and joe biden and kamala
harris and nancy pelosi and gay pete and
all of these people that they represent
you or that they're competent
professionals who should be in the jobs
that they are in so this book in many
ways it's going to be a nudge and a
needle and a little bit of a push on the
moderate democrat but absolutely i mean
look at the end of the day
if i'm not moderate enough for a
democrat then then maybe they're more of
a socialist or a communist or marxist
than a democrat uh karen
karen i hope you're not a karen karen
karen says
will there be a third book well
look the the title of this book is don't
burn this country
and i suppose if the country burns down
in the course of the next year before i
can publish another book then there
won't be because it'll all be over and
there'll be just a few of us left there
will be a zombie apocalypse and we'll be
eating brains and it'll be well that's
just sort of the natural trajectory if
biden stays in charge there'll be no
food on the shelves and you know the
apocalypse will be here yes i suspect
there will be a third book i now see
this sort of as a trilogy so the first
book
was me laying out the best ideas that i
know of for western society to flourish
and for the individual to flourish this
book is okay those are the ideas but how
do you actually put them into practice
i've tried to explain a little bit of
that to you today being less reliant on
these systems not bowing to the mob all
of that and then the third one i suspect
is they're not going to stop they're not
going to stop so what does a future
america really look like i actually hint
to that at the end of this book probably
i would yeah the prologue to this book
is probably where the beginning of the
next book will pick up so if you
remember
when karate kid
ended karate kid 2 took place right in
the parking lot right after the all
valley tournament in encino where i used
to live by the way in los angeles um
that was before i lived there but
nonetheless uh and i like that i always
loved that how cool like they end karate
kid this amazing movie you remember the
last scene in karate kid it's just mr
miyagi smiling he's just like
like that and then next thing you know
next thing you know
they splash forward to karate kid part
two and it's the parking lot of the
event that was just happening i sense
that's what's going to happen with this
book because i kind of hint at what a
future america will look like in the
prologue man give me two more minutes
give me two more minutes i'll do them
quick give me some questions quick
karen will be a third book we just did
that one give me something something
else anything one more question
fast man i'm just signing things while
i'm waiting i'm signing things so
am i having any locals meetups yes
so uh one of the things that we did a
whole bunch of in in los angeles and
then i would do it when i was traveling
we did them in nashville we did them in
dallas a bunch of other places where
these locals community meetups i can't
just meet the average people i can't
just say on youtube i'm going to be here
show up and meet me because not everyone
likes me i know that's weird but not
everybody does but we do these locals
meetups we haven't done one in florida
yet but yes we were gonna oh no we did
do one in miami but before i moved here
but we will do a miami meet up at a bar
we will or a bar a restaurant we
actually have a good outdoor location
that i want to do where we're just going
to take over and hopefully you know we
get a couple dozen if not 100 or more
people uh just hanging out and having
drinks and shooting the [ __ ] as they say
and having a good time so we will do
more of those and if you want to meet me
over the next couple months uh
daverubin.com events we're bouncing
around all over the place with the tour
and another reminder the orlando show
which was supposed to be on monday
it is not cancelled it is postponed
because we got the guest of all guests
the guy that i would want to talk to
more than anybody else oh but now i said
it was a guy but i'm not a biologist so
maybe it's a chick who the hell knows
okay uh but we will be moving that date
we can hopefully update you as soon as
possible maybe even later today we're
just waiting on a signature on something
and uh then we will do the orlando show
disney happens to be in orlando they'll
be very happy that i'm in town this is
very exciting i'm dropping hints like
you can't believe people uh if you want
to join me on any of the other stops
including the florida ones west palm and
clearwater dave rubin.com events and
yeah for the next 17 minutes i'm gonna i
didn't sign enough of these while i was
doing this obviously i didn't get to as
many as possible um but for the next 17
minutes i will sign as many possible
things as you guys submit so even though
i can't sign them all in 17 minutes if i
get 500 more sales right now or 10 000
more sales i will sign every single one
we'll get that out to you davereuben.com
book and just forward
your receipt over to contact
reubenreport.com at noon today i'm
joining megyn kelly for the hour on her
show
i did a podcast exclusive with ben
shapiro that should be up a little bit
later and uh am i doing anything on fox
tonight i did foxy friends this morning
i think i think i'm on kennedy i'm on
kennedy's program this evening she wears
thick rimmed glasses that kennedy that
libertarian kennedy i'm also doing the
eric mataxis show a little later today
will kane's podcast uh and a whole bunch
of stuff this week you will be sick of
me by the end of the week i
will be sick of me by the end of the
week uh on that note
thank you guys this is a big day i know
this is a little bit of a of an offshoot
show for us today but just thank you for
all of your support i promise if you get
the book you're going to dig it and find
the ideas in it valuable and and this is
going to be a remember this day how
about that remember april 12
2022 because for a long time we've
talked about ideas we've called out the
morons now it's time to shift into
the new mode and the new mode is how do
we how do we escape
how do we build how do we win those are
the directions that i want to go in uh
those are the those are the ideas that i
want to focus on and that's how we will
get out of this madness and i promise
you that we will i know we all feel like
we're in something that we can't get out
of we can get out of it humans have been
through worse than this
and uh
the best is yet to come
i'm dave rubin the book is don't burn
this country and i'll see you tomorrow